[Applause]
that roar belongs to one of the most
iconic movie monsters of all time
Godzilla since his debut in 1954 the
king of Monsters has rampaged across
Tokyo New York City and Osaka to name a
few and over the years he's gotten
bigger and bigger and bigger
the latest Godzilla is a record 119
meters tall about six times taller than
the tallest animal in history and to be
fair it's a fantasy film not a nature
documentary
but just how fantastical is a 36 story
tall lizard dinosaur creature who
breathes beams of atomic energy
well energy beams aside Godzilla is
actually even more unrealistic than you
might think now earth is no stranger to
enormous animals just look at the
largest dinosaur the titanosaurs or
today's blue whales which reach up to 30
meters long and can weigh 200 tons
compared to them
Godzilla doesn't seem that impossible
right these critters are massive on a
scale that's just totally impossible
soomi at least they're made of anything
even remotely like what we're made out
of at fault any of the rules of biology
they are they're completely impossible
that's paleontologist Mike Habib he's an
expert in giant reptiles and also helps
design fantastical creatures for TV and
film and according to him a creature
like a Dilla could never exist in real
life
for multiple reasons first he would be
brain dead long before he ever reached a
city because his heart simply isn't
large and powerful enough to pump blood
to his head his heart would have to be
you know thousands of tons that fill
most of his chest you'd have to have
vessels that you could drive a car
through
and and he you know he would need you
know he needed the energy consumption of
a small power plant probably every
minute in order to run it of course
these nuclear power and so maybe he has
the energy of this family in reality
large animals like titanosaurs got
around this by walking on all fours with
their heads held out in front of them
not held up high that way they don't
have to pump blood against gravity as
far but even if Godzilla did crawl
across cities on all fours
he'd have another problem movement see
whenever you lift your leg or arm it's
because your brain fire signals to the
nerves in your leg and arm muscles the
fastest of these signals travel around a
hundred meters per second so the message
from brain to leg is virtually
instantaneous not for Godzilla though it
would take more than a full second for
nerve signals to travel the length of
his body
now a second still sounds pretty quick
but in reality his nerve conduction
speed becomes so slow that he can't move
takes forever to do anything now
Godzilla does look pretty sluggish in
the films but it turns out in reality it
would look more like this
[Music]
but even if Godzilla could move super
fast he wouldn't have time to fight
enemies or demolish buildings because
he'd be too busy sunbathing all animals
need a way to regulate body temperature
reptiles and other cold-blooded animals
stay warm by basking in the Sun but in
Godzilla's case heat from the Sun would
have to travel through meters upon
metres of tissue to penetrate his hide
and reach his internal organs so to stay
warm
he'd have to spend hundreds of hours
straight sunbathing but what if Godzilla
were more like a mammal like us he
wouldn't need to rely on the Sun since
we warm-blooded creatures produce our
own body heat but unfortunately that
would cause yet another problem but did
he still baby probably he probably cooks
himself his core temperature at 300
degrees yikes and even if he somehow got
around all these problems his skeleton
would still collapse under its own
weight now mike says he's a whopping 90
thousand metric tons and that skeleton
is just not strong enough to support
ninety thousand metric tons of wealth
anything yeah he would just be a very
large pile of meat not a very
intimidating picture in the end mike
says Godzilla could only be about half
as tall as he was in the original film
before his poor heart would give out but
just because Godzilla's body is
unrealistic doesn't mean it's bad in
fact he's perfect for the role he's tall
enough to stock past city skyscrapers
which give us iconic scenes
just straight-up magic in the modern
world setting and just go in and enjoy
it as such
[Music]